marriage is very risky
because you can't control people i can't
control how what kind of emotions you're
gonna have what's gonna happen to you
she can't do it to me but from day one
we said babe one ear at a time
no pressure perfection the pressure
perfection of marriage
ruins everybody you're always worried
about what if this doesn't work out what
if this what if i become like my parents
what if all that stuff
and that pressure doesn't allow you to
enjoy your marriage so we said
babe i think we can be married one more
year we've been saying this for 11 years
so we'll see how many more times we're
going to say this wow yeah slightly
different
where do you think you'd be if you were
single over the last 11 years
you weren't married didn't have kids
would you be farther along in your
financial no
success and fulfillment success or does
this bring you more financial and inner
fulfillment well
the the the like when you're married
there is just as much of a target on you
when you're married when you're single
you have to understand how so because
you're a target
you're somebody that's taken it's a
challenge desirable it's a
challenge it's a challenge you have to
check yourself all the time
oh it's amazing i have a formula last
week i was like
tell me this and camera here but the
formula i can tell you privately but
i i'm at west palm and i started sharing
this formula with our married guys i
said guys hey listen
i said them with three guys i said you
guys are all good-looking okay one guy's
name is
got money you're good-looking you're
good looking these guys are all like
good looking one guy went to apu the
other guy's a butcher from jersey
who had a broadway show in new york and
the other guy was a calvin klein model
six four curtis eatman
i'm saying well guys you're very good
looking now good news is you guys all
married well you're you're you have
beautiful wives i said but don't get it
twisted yeah
you know when you're by yourself and you
you're you're you're a target as well so
you gotta have a system
so i told them the system when i told
them the system they sat there they're
like it was the uncomfortable moment
and i see yeah this is very effective
just so it gives you two
hours of savings okay if you do this
exercise that i'm telling you
and while i'm telling them their face is
turning red and then their wives come so
what are you guys talking about i said
yeah andrew why don't you tell your wife
what we're talking about baby you know
what
you know so you know the difference if i
was single it would have been more women
it would have been more dating it would
have been more
relationship it would have been more
trying to please her and her
and her and consuming my time and and
the desire to try to please
you know however many relationships you
have it's too much of getting into a
relationship ending all the
relationships
managing the energy the energy of trying
to
you know like everybody you date for the
first time you're like
heaven on earth i wish the last one was
like her
oh my gosh and then one's issue is she
bites her nails
another one's issue is she doesn't like
to floss
so when you're making out at night
there's a little bit of the i'm like
give me a freaking break go floss
already no it's something another one is
her mother and her mother is like so
annoying she wants to tell you what to
do and you're so sick of it
another one is her dad is the opinions
on how you should do everything and she
listens to her dad and
your number two as a man there's so many
things so you have to eventually make a
decision which one
right what are the most the annoying
things that you're willing to work with
because they're not going away
everyone's gonna have something
you got willing to accept something